My name is Diakolola Amujo. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information information on the UK declineside application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of
我叫 Diakolola Amujo。我刚从爱尔兰心理学专业毕业，也是一名临床心理学准研究生。Marion 博士的著作《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中给予了我极大的帮助。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学博士申请流程的深入信息，这对我来说非常有用。我很高兴读到了
both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. Imagine leaving prison, hopeful, changed, determined to start again, and within 48 hours you're sleeping on the street, hungry, scared and completely alone. Sadly, that's the reality for so many people every year in the UK. In this episode, I'm joined by Dr. Tanya and Natalie, who both work within prison mental health
合格的临床心理学家和实习临床心理学家的经历。书中的各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都各不相同，这为临床心理学之旅提供了令人惊叹的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。想象一下，你怀着希望、改变和重新开始的决心离开监狱，但 48 小时内你却露宿街头，饥肠辘辘，恐惧且孤立无援。可悲的是，这正是英国每年许多人的现实。在这一集中，我邀请到了 Tanya 博士和 Natalie，她们都在监狱心理健康
services. Together, we are pulling back the curtain on what really happened. when someone leaves prison, the chaos, the system failures and the small extraordinary moments that keep hope alive. We are talking about trauma, about institutionalisation and the emotional toll this work takes on staff who care deeply but can't always change the system. This episode is a raw and compassionate look at the human side of rehabilitation and a reminder that us and them might be far closer than we think.
服务部门工作。我们将共同揭开当某人离开监狱时到底发生了什么：混乱、系统性失败，以及那些让希望得以延续的微小而非凡的时刻。我们谈论的是创伤、机构化，以及这份工作给那些深切关心却无法总是改变体制的工作人员带来的情感负担。这一集是对康复人性化一面的真实而富有同情心的审视，并提醒我们，“我们”与“他们”之间的距离可能比我们想象的要近得多。
Hope you find it really useful and if you do, please like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Today I am joined by not one but two guests. We've got Dr. Tanya Rodriguez, who is a consultant clinical psychologist. And we've got Natalie Miller, who's a deputy regional manager, and Tanya and Natalie both work for the same organisation. Just to kind of set the context for what we're talking about, Natalie,
希望你觉得这很有用，如果确实如此，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到“有抱负的心理学家播客”。我是 Marianne 博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天我邀请到了两位嘉宾。我们有临床心理学顾问 Tanya Rodriguez 博士，还有区域副经理 Natalie Miller。Tanya 和 Natalie 都在同一家机构工作。为了让我们谈论的内容更有背景，Natalie，
you first caught my eye on LinkedIn, because you made a really powerful and interesting post about what the reality is like for people when they leave prison. When they go from perhaps having really good intentions, they've had some really good rehab work, They're really thinking about, you know, this new kind of genesis of their life. People know their names, you know, people are on their side. And then, you know, they're released, they're discharged, whatever the right term is these days.
你最初引起我的注意是在 LinkedIn 上，因为你发布了一篇关于人们离开监狱后现实生活是什么样子的、非常有力和有趣的帖子。当他们从可能怀有非常好的意图、接受了一些非常好的康复工作，并且真的在思考他们生活的新开端时。人们知道他们的名字，人们站在他们这一边。然后，你知道，他们被释放了，出狱了，或者现在用什么合适的术语都行。
And very quickly, the wheels can fall off. Could you talk to us a little bit about that post and about about that kind of concept and reality? Thank you. Yeah, absolutely. My post was to talk about and highlight when people come to prison, they're not coming in from, you know, a stable, you know, everything working for them in the community outside. They're coming in with perhaps chaos already happening outside, already trauma. You know, there's a lot before somebody comes into prison, which, you know, they're not coming in and they're a prisoner, but they're a person who's got loads of other things going on. and we do our really best to support them in prison and to try to find out what their needs are
很快，一切就可能分崩离析。你能跟我们谈谈那篇帖子以及那种概念和现实吗？谢谢。好的，没问题。我的帖子是为了讨论和强调，当人们进入监狱时，他们并不是从社区外一个稳定、一切顺利的环境中进来的。他们进来时，外面可能已经是一片混乱，已经有了创伤。在某人进入监狱之前，有很多事情发生，他们进来时不仅仅是一个囚犯，而是一个经历了很多其他事情的人。我们尽最大努力在监狱里支持他们，并试图找出他们的需求，
so that we can meet them. And sometimes we do better than others and we have a little bit longer time. Sometimes we don't have enough time because of the short sentences, but we do make progress with the people that come inside. And then they go back out into the community. But unfortunately, nothing else,
以便我们能满足这些需求。有时我们做得比其他时候好，我们有稍微多一点的时间。有时由于刑期较短，我们没有足够的时间，但我们确实在与进来的人一起取得进展。然后他们回到社区。但不幸的是，没有其他东西，
their life outside didn't progress forward. their life outside is exactly the same as how they left it when they came in. So they might have progressed further in themselves inside, but then they go back out, they still might not have a home to go to or a job or money in the bank or they've got problems with their family or there's the life they went back to that led them to addiction or the crime or any other kind of negative impact on their life is still there waiting for them. And because those tides don't always link up very well, and we can't resolve everything in that short time, they see no other option.
他们外面的生活并没有向前发展。他们外面的生活和他们进来时离开时一模一样。所以他们自己在里面可能进步了，但当他们出去时，他们可能仍然没有家可回，没有工作，银行里没有钱，或者他们有家庭问题，或者他们回到的生活导致了他们成瘾、犯罪或任何其他对他们生活产生负面影响的事情，这些依然在那里等着他们。由于这些环节并不总是能很好地衔接，而且我们无法在那么短的时间内解决所有问题，他们看不到其他选择。
But to go back to what they had before, it's easier because it's there. And there's no one else kind of holding their hands and putting their arms around them and kind of saying, well, no, actually go this way. They're just left out there with nothing, really. So, yeah, that kind of was what I wanted to talk about. And it is really sad. And we forget that when people go, when people leave prison, and we just say by and they've gone and there's someone else's responsibility now,
只能回到他们以前拥有的东西，因为这更容易，因为它就在那里。没有其他人牵着他们的手，拥抱他们，告诉他们：“不，其实走这边。”他们只是被留在那里，真的什么都没有。所以，是的，这就是我想谈论的。这真的很可悲。我们忘记了，当人们离开监狱时，我们只是说再见，他们走了，现在是别人的责任了，
but who's out there picking up those pieces that we've released? Yeah, and sometimes the answer is no one. No one's picking up those pieces. I guess people will have a probation officer, but that's not always, well, often not an attuned experience, I know individual differences, but sometimes I think it feels like there's not anyone really on your team and kind of necessarily as trauma-informed as you might want people to be.
但是谁在外面收拾我们释放的那些残局呢？是的，有时答案是没人。没人收拾那些残局。我想人们会有缓刑监督官，但这并不总是，嗯，通常不是一种协调一致的体验。我知道个体差异，但有时我觉得好像真的没有人站在你这一边，也没有像你希望的那样具备创伤知情意识。
Who wants to talk to that point? What is life like when, you know, for actual practical support when you leave prison? So there is support out there. And that's the frustrating thing is that there is pockets of amazing support out there in all over the country. It exists. Unfortunately, there isn't enough of it. There's not enough people to deliver it.
谁想谈谈这一点？当你离开监狱时，实际的实际支持是什么样的？所以外面确实有支持。令人沮丧的是，全国各地都有很棒的支持点。它确实存在。不幸的是，支持还不够。没有足够的人来提供它。
enough training to keep up that consistency. There isn't enough support around it while we're doing it, the supervision, the understanding, you need to have those constant conversations. And we know that staff leave positions, organisations change, contract change, the systemic barriers that exist, those things will cause the other things not to work very well. So we can have the great people and the great services and the great ideas and all that innovation exists there. But we're just not quite able to tie it together long enough consistently. I mean, that's how I feel. I'm not sure how Tanya's thoughts.
没有足够的培训来保持这种一致性。我们在做这件事时，周围没有足够的支持，比如督导、理解，你需要进行那些持续的对话。我们知道员工会离职，组织会变动，合同会变更，存在的系统性障碍会导致其他事情无法很好地运作。所以我们可以有很棒的人、很棒的服务、很棒的想法，所有这些创新都存在。但我们只是无法足够长久、足够一致地将它们联系在一起。我是这么觉得的。我不确定 Tanya 的想法。
No, absolutely, Natalie. I would absolutely agree with you. I think the other fallacy for us is that, you know, it's not a linear journey. You know, people coming to prison and all sorts of things are still happening in the background, you know, in many ways their lives are paused in certain areas. But in other areas, things continue.
不，绝对是这样，Natalie。我完全同意你的观点。我认为对我们来说另一个谬论是，这不是一段线性的旅程。人们进入监狱，背景中仍然发生着各种各样的事情，在许多方面，他们的生活在某些领域是暂停的。但在其他领域，事情仍在继续。
So, for example, we have a lot of people that as they're coming to prison, they've left a home behind that may or may not be taken away. And so whilst they are with us, there's still things going on in the background to decide whether they will keep their property or not. And sometimes these things are not known, not known by them, not known by the team supporting them. So by the time that they're ready to leave prison, we're not always sure what the answer is going to be. And that is the same thing for families. You know, we have people that come into prison with relationships that by the time they leave, prison relationships have ended. And my focus often is thinking about women
例如，我们有很多人在进入监狱时，留下了一个家，这个家可能被收走，也可能不会。所以当他们和我们在一起时，背景中仍然有事情在进行，以决定他们是否能保住自己的财产。有时这些事情他们不知道，支持他们的团队也不知道。所以当他们准备离开监狱时，我们并不总是确定结果会是什么。家庭也是如此。我们有的人进入监狱时，关系在他们离开时已经结束了。我的关注点通常是女性，
because I find that women are perhaps the most affected when it comes to family breakdowns because they're usually the ones caring for children. And because we have such a high number of women that come into prison for very short sentences, it means that we don't have enough time to plan their care in the way there would be clearly managed
因为我发现女性在家庭破裂时受到的影响最大，因为她们通常是照顾孩子的人。而且因为我们有大量女性因非常短的刑期进入监狱，这意味着我们没有足够的时间以那种明确管理的方式来规划她们的护理，
inside and outside the prison in terms of communication with external agencies and to make that care planning in the way that is meaningful. But already, the fact that they've come into prison means that children have been left with no care might have been taken into care or been left with other families.
在监狱内外，在与外部机构沟通方面，以及以有意义的方式进行护理规划。但事实上，她们进入监狱意味着孩子无人照看，可能已经被送去寄养或留给了其他家庭。
And by the time that these women are ready them to live, prison, relationships have been torn. You know, some people might not want to then accept them back into the families. And that has a massive impact, not just at that individual, but then we're starting to see the ripple effects on families and children and intergenerational trauma and all the things that, you know, that we understand. So I guess the lack of, you know, understanding that the journey is not linear is that it doesn't follow a process where you come in and everything else is being done at the same time. You know, we all have different priorities, services of different priorities. We have finite resources,
当这些女性准备离开监狱时，关系已经破裂了。有些人可能不想再接受她们回到家庭。这产生了巨大的影响，不仅是对个人，而且我们开始看到对家庭和儿童的连锁反应，以及代际创伤和我们所理解的所有事情。所以我认为，缺乏对旅程不是线性的理解，意味着它不遵循一个流程，即你进来，同时其他一切都在完成。我们都有不同的优先事项，服务有不同的优先事项。我们有有限的资源，
both in prison and in the community. And so things are not very aligned. I think one of my biggest frustrations always has been as a clinician is never fully knowing how much time do I have to work with an individual because actually it's beyond my control. So I can have the best plan for that person and then halfway through that plant, they just disappear into the ether of the system because they've been transferred, they've been released. And so there isn't enough time to have the kind of planning that we would like to have to make sure that by the time that the people come out of prison, the system is ready to accept them and to receive them. And like Natalie was saying, you know, we all people. So everything that we do is based on relationships. And I have worked
无论是在监狱还是在社区。所以事情并不是很协调。我认为作为一名临床医生，我最大的挫折之一是永远不知道我有多少时间与一个人一起工作，因为实际上这超出了我的控制。所以我可以为那个人制定最好的计划，然后计划进行到一半，他们就消失在系统的以太中了，因为他们被转移了，被释放了。所以没有足够的时间进行我们想要的规划，以确保当人们走出监狱时，系统已经准备好接受他们。就像 Natalie 说的，我们都是人。所以我们所做的一切都基于关系。我曾与
with amazing colleagues in probation that really have taken the time to go above and beyond to think about what will this person need upon release. But even when they have done their best job and they've done everything, they've thought about everything, we are then dependent upon external services capacity to offer those services at the time that that person is ready to engage with them,
缓刑部门的优秀同事一起工作，他们确实花时间去超越自我，思考这个人出狱后需要什么。但即使他们尽了最大努力，做了所有事情，考虑了一切，我们仍然依赖于外部服务在个人准备好参与时提供这些服务的能力，
which is the other thing, because not everybody leaves prison and they're absolutely ready to engage with that service for different reasons because priorities are different. You know, my priority as a clinician when I think about somebody living the prison might be that the first thing that we need to do is to make sure that you register with a GP because from our point, from a clinical point of view, we want to make sure that the healthcare needs are dealt with immediately. Whereas the priority for that individual might be that they need to have money because they need to eat or they need to find a place to sleep.
这是另一回事，因为不是每个人离开监狱时都绝对准备好参与该服务，原因各不相同，因为优先事项不同。你知道，作为一名临床医生，当我考虑某人离开监狱时，我的优先事项可能是我们需要做的第一件事是确保你注册了全科医生（GP），因为从临床角度来看，我们希望确保医疗保健需求得到立即处理。而那个人的优先事项可能是他们需要钱，因为他们需要吃饭，或者他们需要找个地方睡觉，
or they need to know if their children are okay. So I think we're always running against everybody else's priorities and we're fighting against resources, whether we like it or not. And so that complicates matters. So it's not to say that there aren't services available, there are, but the services are not, you know, the numbers are not there. The capacity is not there. And then the priorities, the agendas are not always aligned.
或者他们需要知道他们的孩子是否还好。所以我认为我们总是在与别人的优先事项赛跑，无论我们是否喜欢，我们都在与资源作斗争。这使事情变得复杂。所以并不是说没有可用的服务，有，但服务数量不够。能力不足。而且优先事项、议程并不总是协调一致的。
So that makes things really difficult. Yeah, and it really is a very different way of working with people, isn't it? If you, you know, often we will kind of even informally contract or in our minds will be thinking, oh, this might be kind of a 10 to 12 session piece of work, but it's almost like you're having to almost do every single bit of work that you do as a potentially single session intervention because you just don't know what's going to happen. But it's really tricky if you're trying to do some kind of stabilization work, or kind of work through someone's trauma that might be kind of really leading to some of the
这使得事情变得非常困难。是的，这确实是一种与人合作的非常不同的方式，不是吗？如果你，你知道，我们通常甚至会非正式地签约，或者在我们的脑海中会想，哦，这可能是一个 10 到 12 次的疗程，但几乎就像你必须把你所做的每一部分工作都当作潜在的单次干预，因为你根本不知道会发生什么。但如果你试图做一些稳定工作，或者试图解决某人的创伤，这可能确实导致了一些
behaviours and some of the kind of life choices that lead them to offending behaviour if you don't get to finish that because it's really hard to open up and kind of have that. I think what we don't often realise is therapy is a, in psychology, any kind of work is intimate, right? And to open yourself up and be vulnerable, not knowing if you'll ever see, see that person again, that takes a great deal of trust. And if we're asking people who have often been let down by people to put that trust in people, that's really tricky, isn't it? Very, very tricky. It's not just about not knowing about when the end is going to be. It's also taking into account that it takes time to build trust. So when you are in a chaotic environment, when, you know,
行为和一些导致他们犯罪行为的生活选择，如果你不能完成它，那就真的很棘手，因为很难敞开心扉并拥有那种。我认为我们经常没有意识到的是，治疗在心理学中，任何形式的工作都是亲密的，对吧？要敞开心扉并变得脆弱，不知道你是否还会再见到那个人，这需要极大的信任。如果我们要求那些经常被别人辜负的人把这种信任放在别人身上，那真的很棘手，不是吗？非常非常棘手。这不仅仅是不知道结束时间是什么时候。还要考虑到建立信任需要时间。所以当你处于一个混乱的环境中，当，你知道，
in most cases, a lot of the people that we work with have already been failed by services, time and time again. They probably have already started these types of conversations with 10 different members of staff and now I'm asking the same questions or similar questions that they've already repeated 10 times before. It doesn't lend itself to feel very trusting of the process. So it takes time to build trust. By the time you're starting to perhaps build trust or start to see that maybe it's worth investing your time, all of a sudden maybe there's a change, you know, and you're now going to be released or you're going to be transferred and you've just open a kind of worms halfway through those interventions and you have to think okay is this the right time to do the
在大多数情况下，我们合作的许多人已经被服务一次又一次地辜负了。他们可能已经与 10 个不同的工作人员开始了这些类型的对话，现在我正在问他们之前已经重复了 10 次的相同问题或类似问题。这不利于对这个过程产生信任感。所以建立信任需要时间。当你开始可能建立信任或开始看到也许值得投入你的时间时，突然之间也许有了一个变化，你知道，你现在要被释放了，或者你要被转移了，你刚刚在这些干预措施进行到一半时打开了一个潘多拉的盒子，你必须想，好吧，这是做这项工作的正确时间吗？
work so one of the things that we we need to be really clear and really careful is that not everybody in prison is at a level that they are ready or it's right to even start any kind of trauma focus therapy because the environment itself is not safe so why would we do that so it is important absolutely to invest in building stabilization skills, emotional regulation skills. It is important to start giving people a sense of autonomy and a sense of, you know, control over their own environment and choices and empowering them to take on a more collaborative approach. But we have to be really careful that we always have to think that every session could be the last session. And it's very different if you're working in a cat, a prison where you've
所以我们需要非常清楚和非常小心的一件事是，并不是监狱里的每个人都处于他们准备好或开始任何形式的创伤聚焦治疗是正确的水平，因为环境本身并不安全，所以我们为什么要这样做呢？所以投资于建立稳定技能、情绪调节技能绝对很重要。开始给人们一种自主感和对他们自己环境和选择的控制感，并赋予他们采取更协作方式的能力，这很重要。但我们必须非常小心，我们总是必须认为每一次会议都可能是最后一次会议。如果你在监狱工作，那里有
got people that might be there for 10, 15, 20 years. But the majority of people that we work in remand prisons could be there. I mean, female prisons, the kind of the shortest that we have is about 10 days. You know, what exactly do you do in 10 days? You know, remand prisons, male prisons, we pretend about four weeks, isn't it, Natalie? So, I mean, when you think about it, and you think is it even safe to start having those conversations? Because you also know that when people leave prison, they need to survive out there. And we may not like to say this or to think about this, but a lot of the things that we deem to be unhealthy and risky are really survival mechanisms that allow them to still be around. And without them, they wouldn't survive. So we have to
人们可能在那里待 10、15、20 年，情况就非常不同了。但我们在还押监狱工作的大多数人可能在那里。我的意思是，女子监狱，我们最短的刑期大约是 10 天。你知道，你在 10 天内到底能做什么？你知道，还押监狱，男子监狱，我们假设大约四周，对吧，Natalie？所以，我的意思是，当你想到它，当你想到开始那些对话是否安全时？因为你也知道，当人们离开监狱时，他们需要在外面生存。我们可能不喜欢说这个或考虑这个，但许多我们认为不健康和有风险的事情实际上是让他们仍然存在的生存机制。没有它们，他们就无法生存。所以我们必须
always be thinking about what is the best that can be done right now for this, person with the knowledge that there's a lot of uncertainty around what it is that we're trying to achieve. And that's equally difficult for the individuals, the patients, the prisons we work with. It's also really hard on the staff because most staff, most of us always are thinking that we want to make sure that we do the best that we can with that individual. And we're always thinking about the long term. We've seen them today but thinking the long term is they going to go back into the community. So we want to think what we need to do to get them ready for that, but we might not really have the ability to work with them for that amount of time.
总是考虑现在能为这个人做的最好的事情是什么，并知道关于我们试图实现的目标存在很多不确定性。这对个人、病人、我们合作的囚犯来说同样困难。这对员工来说也非常困难，因为大多数员工，我们大多数人总是认为我们想确保我们对那个人尽我们所能。我们总是考虑长期。我们今天见到了他们，但考虑长期是他们是否会回到社区。所以我们想考虑我们需要做什么来让他们为此做好准备，但我们可能真的没有能力在那么长的时间内与他们一起工作。
Yeah, absolutely. And the episode before this one is with a guy called Chris Dorr KC, who is the author of Justice on trial. I know Natalie and I, we spoke about him briefly in our DMs, but he's really like, well, what is the point in a sentence of a month? You know, if you're always... just seeing people for 10 days, what is the point? Like, why are we ripping people's families apart? Why are we giving them that prison time? Why are we forcing that shame upon them? Surely there must be something better that you can do or kind of, yeah, like offer as a sense of justice or something than, you know, than a one month sentence or less than that. Like, is this a system that's fit for purpose. And then the really tricky thing is, is that you guys are then
是的，绝对是。这一集之前的那一集是关于一个叫 Chris Dorr KC 的人，他是《审判中的正义》（Justice on Trial）的作者。我知道 Natalie 和我在私信中简短地谈论过他，但他真的就像，好吧，一个月刑期的意义是什么？你知道，如果你总是……只是见人 10 天，意义何在？就像，我们为什么要拆散人们的家庭？我们为什么要给他们那段监狱时间？我们为什么要强加那种羞耻感给他们？肯定有比一个月刑期或更短时间更好的事情你可以做，或者提供某种正义感。就像，这是一个适合目的的系统吗？然后真正棘手的事情是，你们然后
having to be in the justice system and maybe people are not always feeling that warmly towards you because they kind of, I guess they're thinking of you as the bad guys, the others. Does that play out with you guys, Natalie? Absolutely, it does. It's difficult, isn't it? Because prisons weren't, they're not a healthcare setting. They're not. They're not, a therapeutic setting generally, you know, these are buildings that were built for punishment. They're built to give people punishment for crimes they've done. So we're in the business of rehabilitation, that's not what we're here for. So we're trying to rehabilitate people as a whole as a person. And, you know, as, as Tanya mentioned, there were so many elements to that, you know, it's not just
不得不身处司法系统中，也许人们并不总是对你们感到那么温暖，因为他们，我猜他们把你们视为坏人，其他人。这在你们身上体现出来了吗，Natalie？绝对是这样。这很困难，不是吗？因为监狱不是医疗环境。它们不是。它们通常不是治疗环境，你知道，这些是为惩罚而建造的建筑物。它们是为了给人们所犯的罪行提供惩罚而建造的。所以我们从事的是康复工作，这不是我们在这里的目的。所以我们试图作为一个整体、作为一个人来康复人们。而且，正如 Tanya 提到的，这其中有很多要素，你知道，这不仅仅是
that, you know, someone comes into prison and we've just given them psychological therapies or medication, they'll be having contact with so many different services across primary care and mental health and potentially external secondary care services as well. And we're facilitating all of that. But ultimately, it is bringing somebody into prison for 10 days or two weeks, four weeks does more damage, I feel more damage to them than it does help them because they can maybe a taste of what potentially they could get, or maybe they'll see if there is support out there. Or, you know, as Tanya, say, do we start working with them?
某人进入监狱，我们只是给了他们心理治疗或药物，他们将与初级保健和心理健康以及潜在的外部二级保健服务中的许多不同服务进行接触。我们正在促进所有这些。但归根结底，把某人带进监狱 10 天或两周、四周，我觉得对他们的伤害比帮助他们更大，因为他们可能尝到了他们可能得到的东西，或者也许他们会看到外面是否有支持。或者，正如 Tanya 所说，我们开始与他们合作了吗？
Do we start talking to them, get them to, you know, do we start trying to, you know, understand what they're feeling or what they're thinking, and then just release them back out into the community with more questions, more, you know, now they're more confused. But hold on the second, we were just starting to get somewhere and now I'm back out here, back in this again. So I don't think that's helpful. There are obviously other things that, there are other services
我们开始与他们交谈，让他们，你知道，我们开始尝试，你知道，理解他们的感受或想法，然后只是把他们释放回社区，带着更多的问题，更多，你知道，现在他们更困惑了。但等一下，我们才刚刚开始有所进展，现在我又回到这里了，又回到了这个循环中。所以我认为这没有帮助。显然还有其他事情，还有其他服务
that support, so we have programs, we use reconnect programs, for example, which supports people when they're released from prison. So they work for people in prison, and then they also connect into the community as well. And they work with them, I'm not sure how long before, a period of time after they leave prison. And they help with things that housing, medication, substance issues, all kind of elements. So there are services like that that do link up and help people once they go out. But they don't always work consistently well. Just as Tanya said, it sounds with resources, staffing, training, lots of other things that mean that that isn't always easy to do. Yeah, like even thinking about where people are going to go, you know, physically. So when I
提供支持，所以我们有项目，例如我们使用“重新连接”（reconnect）项目，它支持人们从监狱释放。所以他们为监狱里的人工作，然后他们也连接到社区。他们与他们一起工作，我不确定在他们离开监狱后的一段时间内。他们帮助解决住房、药物、物质问题等所有要素。所以有像这样的服务确实能联系起来并在他们出去后帮助人们。但它们并不总是能持续良好地运作。正如 Tanya 所说，这听起来与资源、人员配备、培训、许多其他事情有关，这意味着这并不总是容易做到的。是的，甚至想到人们要去哪里，你知道，身体上。所以当我
worked in youth justice, the young people would know they were either going to go home to their families or if they were in care, they were going to go back into a care. setting. Is that the same for adults? Do they always know where they're going to be spending their first night when they're released from prison? I wish that I could say yes to that. I really do. The first 48 hours after someone's released from prison are the highest risk period for self-harm, recall back into prison, relapse. It's a really, really fragile time. the average person will need full custody, they've only served a short sentence. We're not talking long sentences. We know the turnover is huge.
在青少年司法部门工作时，年轻人会知道他们要么回家找家人，要么如果他们在寄养中，他们会回到寄养环境。成年人也是这样吗？他们总是知道他们从监狱释放后的第一晚要在哪里度过吗？我希望我能对那个问题说“是”。我真的希望。某人从监狱释放后的前 48 小时是自残、被召回监狱、复发的最高风险期。这是一个非常、非常脆弱的时间。普通人需要完全监禁，他们只服了短刑期。我们谈论的不是长刑期。我们知道人员流动率很大。
I don't know the numbers, but there are a large amount of people that leave prison and they are homeless or they go into temporary accommodation. And we have to, you know, as a healthcare service, we're trying to register people with GP services. We want to link them up with substance issues, or mental health services in the community. We want to make sure that they can mirror the support we were giving them in prison in the community. And that's really hard to do if someone doesn't have a base. You know, they might have chaotic lifestyles that mean that they are moving from one area to another. They might not have stable relationships or friendships or family.
我不知道具体数字，但有大量的人离开监狱，他们无家可归，或者他们进入临时住所。我们必须，你知道，作为医疗服务，我们试图为人们注册全科医生服务。我们想把他们与物质问题或社区的心理健康服务联系起来。我们想确保他们能镜像我们在监狱里给他们的支持。如果某人没有基地，这真的很难做到。你知道，他们可能有混乱的生活方式，意味着他们从一个地区搬到另一个地区。他们可能没有稳定的关系、友谊或家庭。
They might not have a base. And that means that it's hard to kind of knuckle them down in one area and get that support streamlines into them. But I know that we do have a small number of, I think 15% of prisoners in the UK are released without a GP. registration, which actually is really, really good progress from when we first started registered people with GPs. It wasn't always easy to do. But that is still 15% of people that are leaving prison without a GP. And that means without a GP, they're unable to access other services that they might need. And so it is progress, but it is a real struggle when we're fighting against decisions like putting someone into prison for two weeks, ripping them apart
他们可能没有基地。这意味着很难把他们固定在一个地区，并让那种支持流向他们。但我知道我们确实有少数人，我想英国 15% 的囚犯在没有全科医生注册的情况下被释放，这实际上比我们刚开始为人们注册全科医生时有了非常、非常好的进展。这并不总是容易做到的。但这仍然是 15% 的人在没有全科医生的情况下离开监狱。这意味着没有全科医生，他们无法获得他们可能需要的其他服务。所以这是进步，但当我们与把某人关进监狱两周、拆散他们这样的决定作斗争时，这确实是一个真正的挣扎
from their family and their jobs, you know, they could lose their job because they've now gone into prison. They might have had a stable-ish relationship before they came into prison. They now come in, that's now what to set their relationship, the relationship with their children, with their partners, with their family. So potentially there's a lot more disruption coming from putting someone into prison than there is maybe looking at other services that could help rehabilitate that need. And sometimes we see people come into prison for things that are crimes in the eyes of the law, but ultimately they stem from other problems which could be helped with psychological support, medication, any other kind of healthcare support services
从他们的家庭和工作中，你知道，他们可能会因为现在进了监狱而失去工作。他们在进入监狱之前可能有一段相对稳定的关系。他们现在进来了，那现在是什么，他们的关系，与孩子、伴侣、家人的关系。所以把某人关进监狱带来的破坏可能比看看其他能帮助康复的需要帮助的服务要多得多。有时我们看到人们因为在法律眼中是犯罪的事情进入监狱，但归根结底，它们源于其他问题，这些问题可以通过心理支持、药物、任何其他形式的医疗保健支持服务来帮助，
that could prevent you prevent it from leading to that point that got them into prison in the first place. Yeah, absolutely. I could not agree more. And as I'm kind of listening to you, I'm just really trying to think, gosh, like we're all recording from home today, right? I've even switch the heating on because my son is on teacher training today so it feels like tropical in here like it's it's comfortable and I know that I've made my bed upstairs before we started speaking and you know I know that I'm taking my kids swimming this evening and when I get home my husband will have cooked us dinner like but can I just ask all of our viewers and ourselves really to just take a moment to stop and think what would I be feeling in my body what
这些服务可以防止它导致导致他们进入监狱的那一点。是的，绝对是。我完全同意。当我听你说话时，我真的在努力思考，天哪，我们今天都是从家里录音的，对吧？我甚至打开了暖气，因为我儿子今天在接受教师培训，所以这里感觉像热带一样，很舒服，我知道我在我们开始说话之前整理了床铺，你知道，我知道我今晚要带孩子们去游泳，当我回家时，我丈夫会为我们做晚饭，但是我可以请我们所有的观众和我们自己真的花点时间停下来思考一下，我的身体会有什么感觉，
thoughts would I be having? If I didn't know where I was sleeping tonight and if I didn't know that when I locked my door, that I will be safe and that I won't be kicked out or that I'm only here for a day, let's just take a moment to connect to that because this is what we are asking so many people to do. Carrying that with them, it's massive, really massive. Really massive. What went on for you, Tanya, when I asked you to do that? What were you thinking? I tell you what happened to me, it just took me back to a situation, actually, with a lady that I worked with. She came into prison pregnant and stayed with us probably for about three weeks. And upon release, she had no home to go to. She'd lost a home. She was pregnant.
我会有什么想法？如果我不知道今晚在哪里睡觉，如果我不知道当我锁上门时，我会是安全的，我不会被赶出去，或者我只是在这里待一天，让我们花点时间连接到这一点，因为这就是我们要求这么多人做的事情。带着它，这很沉重，真的非常沉重。非常沉重。当我要求你这样做时，Tanya，你发生了什么？你在想什么？我告诉你我发生了什么，它只是把我带回了一个情况，实际上，和我一起工作的一位女士。她怀孕进入监狱，和我们待了大约三周。在释放时，她没有家可回。她失去了家。她怀孕了。
and she had, she was in a domestically violent relationship when she came into prison. So she couldn't go home because of that. She didn't have a place to go. She didn't have family because people had cut off ties with her. And I remember the panic within the team, the frenzy, when we found out that she was going to be released. and we were all thinking, well, this is a safeguarding concern. She's pregnant.
而且她有，她进入监狱时处于家庭暴力关系中。所以她不能回家，因为那个。她没有地方去。她没有家人，因为人们切断了与她的联系。我记得团队里的恐慌，那种狂热，当我们发现她要被释放时。我们都在想，好吧，这是一个保障问题。她怀孕了。
There's all sorts of things supposed to consider. And I remember the panic. And there was a, and it's, I don't think we often consider that, that we sit with a huge amount of responsibility for these individuals that, you know, we do get to know. And we're all human beings. There are certain people that you connect with more than others. There are certain people that you come to.
有很多事情应该考虑。我记得那种恐慌。而且有一个，我不认为我们经常考虑这一点，我们对这些我们确实了解的个人承担着巨大的责任。我们都是人类。有些人你比其他人联系得更多。有些人你开始
really like them because they are really, you know, pleasant characters to engage with personalities that you come to think, you know what, in different circumstances, this is somebody that could have been a friend of mine, you know, because we are human beings. And I remember when we were together as a team, and I remember looking at some of the women in the team thinking, imagine myself pregnant and going through the situation. And I could see people tearing up just thinking about this. And this is perhaps far more common that we want to give it credit for because we live this day in the out. And although a lot of the times we have to be almost desensitized to cope with the pressure and the nature of the job, when you have a case
真的很喜欢他们，因为他们确实是，你知道，令人愉快的角色，可以与之互动，你开始认为，你知道吗，在不同的情况下，这可能是我的一个朋友，你知道，因为我们是人类。我记得当我们作为一个团队在一起时，我记得看着团队里的一些女性，想象自己怀孕并经历这种情况。我可以看到人们因为想到这一点而流泪。这可能比我们愿意承认的要普遍得多，因为我们日复一日地生活。虽然很多时候我们必须几乎脱敏以应对压力和工作的性质，但当你有一个案例
where you have a minute to really sit with it and think about it, it becomes really overwhelming because we could all end up in a situation like that. So to think about it, I mean immediately my stomach gets in knots, I can just feel it in my stomach. But this is a case that really stuck with me and it stuck with me for several reasons. One because I just thought the whole circumstance of it was just unthinkable. But I also remember the kind of impact it had on the team. And now, you know, and everybody rallied together and everything that we did was the right thing to do. It doesn't necessarily mean that even when we do the best that we can as professional, that he leads to a positive outcome for the individual.
你有时间真正坐下来思考它时，它变得非常令人不知所措，因为我们都可能最终陷入那种境地。所以想到它，我的胃立刻打结了，我能感觉到它在我的胃里。但这是一个真正困扰我的案例，它因为几个原因困扰着我。一个是因为我只是觉得整个情况简直不可思议。但我也记得它对团队产生的影响。现在，你知道，每个人都团结在一起，我们所做的一切都是正确的事情。这并不一定意味着即使我们作为专业人士尽了最大努力，它也会为个人带来积极的结果。
And I think that's one of the hardest realizations in this job, is that we can follow all the processes. We can talk about all the different agencies. We can make all the connections. We can make all the referrals. He still doesn't guarantee success. And that's a really difficult thing to sit with. And for me, sometimes, you know,
我认为这是这份工作中实现的最困难的事情之一，就是我们可以遵循所有的流程。我们可以谈论所有不同的机构。我们可以建立所有的联系。我们可以进行所有的转诊。它仍然不能保证成功。这真的是一件很难坐下来面对的事情。对我来说，有时，你知道，
I'm not above to say that I've lost, sleep over some of the cases that I've worked with, that I've cried, that I've cried with some of my colleagues over some of the cases, because they really get to you. It's impossible not to. So, yeah, when you take a minute to think about that, you know, when you've got children and, you know, another case that sits in my mind, and I'll never forget, is somebody that was so distressed because actually the most valuable, the most strongest attachment they've had was to their dog. And they went into prison, and the dog had to be taken. taken into a kennel. And if it hadn't been paid within a certain amount of time, the dog would
我并不羞于说我因为我合作过的一些案例而失眠，我哭过，我和我的一些同事因为一些案例而哭过，因为它们真的会影响到你。不可能不这样。所以，是的，当你花点时间思考这一点时，你知道，当你有了孩子，你知道，另一个在我脑海中挥之不去的案例，我永远不会忘记，是有人非常痛苦，因为实际上他们拥有的最宝贵、最强大的依恋是他们的狗。他们进了监狱，狗必须被带走。被带进狗舍。如果它没有在一定时间内被支付，狗就会
have been put down. And I, you know, I'm a dog lover, you know, I've got animals. And I couldn't bear the thought of it. So yeah, it's really hard when you actually just take a minute to connect with the human experience that these individuals are going through. I think public opinion is that we detach ourselves. They are criminals. It's us versus. as them. They've done bad things, therefore they have to pay the consequences. What I want to say is, last week I got a fine for speeding. Okay, maybe not my best moment. But that means that I've acted in a way that I knew was wrong, that I've breached the rules. And so there will be consequences. I'm still waiting for the consequence, which I'm hoping is just going to be a fine. And I'm lucky
被安乐死。而且我，你知道，我是一个爱狗人士，你知道，我有动物。我无法忍受那种想法。所以是的，当你真正花点时间连接到这些个人正在经历的人类体验时，这真的很困难。我认为公众舆论是我们脱离了自己。他们是罪犯。这是我们与他们。他们做了坏事，因此他们必须付出代价。我想说的是，上周我因为超速被罚款了。好吧，也许不是我最好的时刻。但这确实意味着我的行为方式我知道是错误的，我违反了规则。所以会有后果。我还在等待后果，我希望这只是罚款。而且我很幸运
enough that I can live with the fact that actually even if it is a fine, I kind of okay enough that I think I can pay the fine. I can afford it. And that's not going to take food out of my plate. But the reality is one could say, well, why would you engage in such behavior if you know it's wrong? Because every day we make decisions at a split of a, you know, a split of a second, you make a decision that may actually change your life. And I was speeding. And I think that I was safe enough in the way that I was driving, that I wasn't going to cause an accident, but what if I had, and what if something had died, and what if I had ended up in prison, and all of a sudden I'm a criminal and a bad person? And I think these are the kind of
足够我可以接受这样一个事实，即即使是罚款，我也觉得还可以，我想我可以支付罚款。我负担得起。这不会从我的盘子里拿走食物。但现实是有人可能会说，好吧，如果你知道它是错的，你为什么要从事这种行为？因为每天我们都在一瞬间做出决定，你知道，一瞬间，你做出一个可能实际上改变你生活的决定。我当时超速了。而且我认为我在驾驶方式上足够安全，我不会造成事故，但如果我造成了呢，如果有人死了呢，如果我最终进了监狱，突然之间我是一个罪犯和一个坏人？而且我认为这些是
things that we don't always allow ourselves to think and to remember that it could be, you know, it could be our, our brother, our sister, our parent, our friend, our neighbor. So I think, connecting with human experience is really important so that we understand what people are going through and that maybe, just maybe, we start to have a think about what do we as a society need to do differently to maybe support these people when they're coming out of prison because it's not just about services providing a service, it's about people coming out and feeling scared for their safety because they might be targeted. You know, all of that plays a role into it. So I think it's such a big question.
我们并不总是允许自己思考和记住的事情，即它可能是，你知道，它可能是我们的，我们的兄弟、姐妹、父母、朋友、邻居。所以我认为，连接人类体验非常重要，这样我们才能理解人们正在经历什么，也许，只是也许，我们开始思考作为社会，我们需要做些什么不同的事情来也许在这些人离开监狱时支持他们，因为这不仅仅是关于服务提供服务，这是关于人们出来并因为他们可能成为目标而感到害怕他们的安全。你知道，所有这些都在其中发挥了作用。所以我认为这是一个如此大的问题。
I'm not sure that I've got the answer, but there's so much to consider. And it does heavy, it's very heavy to think about it. It does way heavy on our shoulders. When the minute you take a moment to really think and connect with it, it's hard. Yeah, it really is. And I think even with the most, the best intentions to go out there and try and create new life for yourself, you know, as you were speaking, I was thinking, well, if, you know, I often do think, God, what if something happened that meant that I had to go to prison? But there would be lots of people that I could call on for emotional support, people that I could call on probably
我不确定我是否找到了答案，但有太多需要考虑的事情了。思考这些问题真的很沉重，它确实压得我们喘不过气来。当你真正花时间去思考并与之产生共鸣时，这很难。是的，确实如此。我认为即使怀着最好的初衷去尝试为自己创造新的生活，就像你刚才说的那样，我常想，天哪，如果发生了什么事导致我必须入狱会怎样？但我会有很多人可以寻求情感支持，可能还有很多人可以寻求
for practical support, you know, I haven't got a dog, but if I did have one, there's probably people I could say, I'm going to be away for four months, could you look after my dog? But often people are really very isolated. And they're, you know, when we're looking at kind of complex trauma, we're like, well, you know, did you have anyone? Did you have a mom or a dad that was kind to you or a granny or an aunt. Even a neighbour, was there anyone who kind of was different, who bucked the trend for people that were unpredictable and unreliable and harmful and abusive? And, you know, sometimes you can dig and dig and dig and you can find one. You can find one example. You're like, lovely. Sometimes you can't. And I think that's the hardest thing to relate to
实际支持。你知道，我没有养狗，但如果我有的话，我可能会对别人说，我要离开四个月，你能帮我照顾一下我的狗吗？但通常人们是非常孤立的。当我们审视复杂的创伤时，我们会问，你身边有人吗？你是否有过善待你的父母、祖父母或阿姨？哪怕是一个邻居，有没有人与众不同，打破了那些不可预测、不可靠、有害和虐待的模式？有时你可以不断挖掘，最终能找到一个例子。你会觉得，太好了。但有时你找不到。我认为这是最难产生共鸣的地方，
is that there hasn't been anyone that's good or safe or that thinks that they're important or a special or worthwhile and that is that is the real difference that can be so hard for people to tune into because they're like well they should have made better choices and it's like well it's actually very very difficult isn't it natalie yeah yeah it is um when tanya was speaking i was smiling because it was very relatable because i i also had speeding fine last year And I also had the same thought process was that, you know, we all are one kind of decision away from where the people that we're looking after in prison are, aren't we? I have bipolar and I have ADHD. And with those, with both of those diagnosis has come some maybe unpredictable behaviours and choices and, you know, some erratic decision making maybe. but I've always been in a position where I've got a network.
那就是身边没有一个善良、安全，或者认为他们重要、特别或有价值的人。这才是真正的区别，人们很难理解这一点，因为他们会觉得，他们本可以做出更好的选择。但实际上这非常非常困难，不是吗，娜塔莉？是的，确实如此。当坦尼娅说话时，我在微笑，因为这非常有共鸣，因为去年我也收到过超速罚单。我也产生过同样的心理过程，你知道，我们所有人距离我们正在监狱里照顾的那些人，其实只有一步之遥，不是吗？我有双相情感障碍和多动症。这两种诊断都可能带来一些不可预测的行为和选择，以及一些反复无常的决策。但我一直处于一个拥有支持网络的处境中。
I've got friends, I've got family, I've got an organisation that I work for that cares about my well-being. I've had access to resources, therapies, support systems that have been able to teach me skills that I need to recognise and work with myself and understand how to manage those emotions or decision-making. They give me the tools that I need to manage my health, prevent me from making silly decisions that can hurt other people or myself. Unfortunately, a lot of the people in prison don't have all those things that I just mentioned. So because they
我有朋友，有家人，有一个关心我福祉的组织。我有机会获得资源、治疗和支持系统，这些系统教会了我识别和处理自身问题所需的技能，并理解如何管理那些情绪或决策。它们给了我管理健康所需的工具，防止我做出可能伤害他人或我自己的愚蠢决定。不幸的是，监狱里的许多人并没有我刚才提到的那些东西。所以因为他们
don't have that, they're not able to prevent and have the tools to make sure that they're safe or that other people around them are safe. And it seems ineffective to me that the best solution for that is to put them into prison, whether that be for two weeks or two years, where that's not helping them get those things and they're still going to come back out without them. I was thinking about when Tanya was speaking, a young lad who I worked with in, who was in one of the prisoners that I worked in. And he was about to be released. And you would think everyone leaving prison would be really excited and happy to be released. But sadly, that's not the case either. He was really, really anxious about being released because he was part of
没有这些，他们无法预防，也没有工具来确保自己或周围人的安全。对我来说，最好的解决办法是把他们关进监狱，无论是两周还是两年，这似乎是无效的，因为这并不能帮助他们获得那些东西，他们出来时依然一无所有。当坦尼娅说话时，我想起了一个我曾共事过的年轻人，他在我工作过的一所监狱里。他即将获释。你可能会认为每个离开监狱的人都会对获释感到非常兴奋和高兴。但遗憾的是，事实并非如此。他非常非常担心获释，因为他是
a gang in the community. And he didn't have any family, no mum, no dad. no friends, the only friendship group that he had, the only support network he had was this group of young men who were in this violent gang. And ultimately, because that was the only supports this thing he had, that's what he was going to go back out to. And he didn't want to, but it's all he knew, it's all he had, that's the only people. And they supported him, you know, they kind of, you know, they spoke to him every day, they came and met him outside of prison, and they wrote to him. They were, to him, what felt like, the supports of the thing he had.
社区里一个帮派的成员。他没有任何家人，没有母亲，没有父亲，没有朋友。他唯一的友谊圈，他唯一的支持网络就是这群在暴力帮派里的年轻人。最终，因为那是他仅有的支持，他只能回到他们身边。他不想这样，但他只知道这些，他只有这些，那是他唯一的人脉。他们支持他，你知道，他们每天都和他说话，在他出狱时来接他，还给他写信。对他来说，这感觉就像是他仅有的支持。
But it was really challenging for us because we knew he was going out to that again. And we obviously don't want to do that. We have to safeguard him. We have to protect him and make sure that he doesn't have to go back out to people he doesn't want to be. So we'd be around. So we have to work with that as well. But there's a lot of people that we released from prison who don't want to go back out there. They even go out and re-offend so they can come back into prison because there's the faces that they know, the nurses, the staff that know their names, that make the effort to talk to them, that there's food, there's a roof over their head, a warm bed at night time, there's friends, there's that culture, that community.
但这对我们来说真的很有挑战性，因为我们知道他又要回到那种生活中去了。我们显然不想那样。我们必须保障他的安全。我们必须保护他，确保他不必回到那些他不想与之共处的人身边。所以我们会在他身边。所以我们也必须处理这个问题。但我们释放的许多人并不想回到那里。他们甚至会再次犯罪，这样就能回到监狱，因为那里有他们熟悉的面孔，有知道他们名字的护士和工作人员，他们会努力与他们交谈，那里有食物，有遮风挡雨的地方，晚上有温暖的床，有朋友，有那种文化，那种社区。
They don't have that outside, so they will come back into prison just so they can experience that again. Yeah, absolutely. It's kind of the concept of institutionalisation, but it goes a step beyond. that actually, doesn't it? Because actually, it's kind of, this is where I feel safest. It's not that I don't know necessarily how to do these for myself. It's that I don't trust the other people around me, whereas I do trust you, Natalie. I do trust you, Tanya. I do trust, you know, what I know. And the unpredictability out there, well, that's not for me. And even things like, my teeth are really hurting. I can't get a dentist appointment. If I'm in prison, that will get sorted. Yeah, it's like a clashes, Nick, between institutionalism and
他们在外面没有这些，所以他们会回到监狱，只是为了再次体验那种感觉。是的，绝对是。这有点像机构化的概念，但它更进了一步，不是吗？因为实际上，这让我感到最安全。并不是说我不知道如何为自己做这些事。而是我不信任周围的其他人，但我信任你，娜塔莉。我信任你，坦尼娅。我信任我所了解的东西。外面的不可预测性，那不适合我。甚至像牙齿很疼，我预约不到牙医。如果我在监狱里，那就能解决。是的，尼克，这就像是机构化与
unstructured freedom. It's that inside, you know, every decision is made for them. When their door gets opened, that decision is made for them. They don't open a door without someone else doing it for them. When they sleep, every, when the light goes on, you know, those decisions are all made for them. And the dentist is there, the physio is there. And services, they probably wouldn't even have thought about accessing maybe in the community. They have right there and there for them in the prison. And then suddenly they go outside. There's this demand for autonomy that maybe they haven't had to deal with for a while and then the disorientation and everything else that will come with that. That can be really hard to function on top of everything else that you're
无序自由之间的冲突。在里面，你知道，每一个决定都是为他们做的。当他们的门被打开时，那个决定是为他们做的。没有别人的帮助，他们无法打开门。当他们睡觉时，灯亮起时，那些决定都是为他们做的。牙医在那里，理疗师在那里。那些服务，他们可能在社区里甚至没想过要去获取，在监狱里却触手可及。然后突然他们出去了。有一种对自主权的需求，他们可能有一段时间没处理过了，随之而来的迷失方向感和其他一切。在处理所有其他事情之上，这真的很难应对。
trying to deal with. Yeah. And actually thinking about that, if my husband wakes me up with the light, I am grumpy with him and with everyone else for a good half. And I probably until I've had a shower really. Like, and this is what we're doing to whole populations of people every day. Like, that's really hard. I've never really considered the light aspect before. And the light aspect is bigger than you think. It really is it. It really is a thing, you know, people, I've been walking on a landing and, you know, a young man, my presence, cell bell, call me to come over. And he said, she's like, please, please turn my light off because someone's walked past turned it on. And, you know, people, I've been walking on. not turned it off and they're like, I can't sleep.
是的。实际上想到这一点，如果我丈夫开灯把我吵醒，我会对他和每个人发半小时的脾气。可能直到我洗完澡才好。就像，这就是我们每天对整个人群所做的事情。这真的很难。我以前从未真正考虑过灯光方面的问题。灯光的影响比你想象的要大。它确实是一个问题，你知道，人们，我曾在走廊上走，一个年轻人，我的囚犯，按了牢房铃叫我过去。他说，请，请把我的灯关掉，因为有人走过把它打开了。而且，你知道，人们，我曾在走廊上走。没有把它关掉，他们会说，我睡不着。
And, you know, it's really stressful that they're in that little box and everything they can control essentially is in that box, but the light. And that's incredibly frustrating. So it sounds like a really small thing to us, you know, like you say, but it is huge for them, really, really huge. Absolutely. I'm just really conscious of the time. And I wonder if there's anything that either one of you think we really should convey
而且，你知道，他们被关在那个小盒子里，他们基本上能控制的一切都在那个盒子里，除了灯光，这真的很让人压力大。这非常令人沮丧。所以对我们来说这听起来是一件很小的事情，就像你说的，但对他们来说这非常巨大，真的非常巨大。绝对是。我非常在意时间。我想知道你们两位是否认为我们今天在结束之前真的应该传达些什么。
today before we finish. I guess, Marianne, I'm just thinking about, I mean, we've been talking a lot about seeing people in prison for the human beings that they are and put a human face behind everything that has brought them into prison. I also want to talk about, you know, public perception and the idea that, you know, there are people that are in prison because they have committed some horrific offenses. You know, we're not trying to minimize or undermine why people may end up in prison. But I do want to make a caveat to say that the majority of people that we work with have actually committed low-level offences for which they end up in prison and complete rupture of their lives and relationships for things that perhaps really we would be better of investing in community, mental health services, in social care services.
我想，玛丽安，我只是在想，我的意思是，我们一直在谈论将监狱里的人视为他们本身的人类，并为所有导致他们入狱的事情背后赋予一个人性化的面孔。我还想谈谈，你知道，公众的看法，以及那种认为，你知道，有些人入狱是因为他们犯下了一些可怕的罪行。你知道，我们并不是要淡化或削弱人们最终入狱的原因。但我确实想提醒一句，我们共事的大多数人实际上犯的是轻微罪行，他们因此入狱，生活和人际关系彻底破裂，而这些事情也许我们最好投资于社区、心理健康服务和社会护理服务。
And I think because the fabric of society is torn, because there's so many things going on at the moment that having a massive impact in the way that we see people, I guess my reflection today is just for us to remind ourselves that actually not everybody that is in prison is there because they've actually committed atrocious offences. That is not the truth. And we do have, you know, high level prisons, high risk prisons for people that have committed those types of offences. And it makes sense that we do need to invest in that too because nobody wakes up a morning and decide I'm just going to go and do something horrific. There's a whole history behind that to consider. So this isn't about excusing or justifying poor behavior or
我认为因为社会结构已经撕裂，因为目前发生了很多事情，对我们看待人的方式产生了巨大的影响，我想我今天的反思只是为了提醒我们自己，实际上并不是每个在监狱里的人都是因为犯下了滔天大罪。那不是事实。我们确实有，你知道，高安全级别的监狱，针对那些犯下此类罪行的人。投资于此也是有道理的，因为没有人会在早上醒来决定我要去干一件可怕的事情。这背后有一整段历史需要考虑。所以这不是为了原谅或辩解不良行为或
criminality. That's not what we're saying. But what we are saying is that behind any kind of crime, there is a story of a person that we need to understand because we have the responsibility of rehabilitating people that come into prison because these people are part of a society that has failed them in the first place for them to end up in prison. And I think for me, it is incredibly important to acknowledge that
犯罪。我们不是在说这个。但我们想说的是，任何犯罪背后都有一个人的故事，我们需要去理解，因为我们有责任改造进入监狱的人，因为这些人本身就是社会的一部分，而社会首先辜负了他们，才导致他们最终入狱。我认为对我来说，承认这一点极其重要，
because we are the ones on a day-to-day basis responsible for making sure that our friends, our neighbours, our families, that they are okay. Because if we start to pay a little bit more attention to the person next to us, then perhaps we might just connect enough with them to give them an escape so that they have somebody to talk to. I think there's so much in the media at the moment about thinking about
因为我们是每天负责确保我们的朋友、邻居、家人安好的人。因为如果我们开始多关注一下身边的人，那么也许我们就能与他们建立足够的联系，给他们一个出口，让他们有人可以倾诉。我认为目前媒体上有很多关于思考
men's mental health and high risk of suicide rates. We know that. But we also know that there is a culture where as much as we want to support men, there's always barriers for that. And we also know that when we start looking at crime and serious crime, the majority of serious crime and serious offences are committed by men. And when we talk about gender-based violence, the majority of those victims are women and girls. But we also know that part of this comes from a position of us having to change the narrative about how we see men in society. We need to do better.
男性心理健康和高自杀率的内容。我们知道这一点。但我们也知道，存在一种文化，尽管我们想支持男性，但总是存在障碍。我们也知道，当我们开始审视犯罪和严重犯罪时，大多数严重犯罪和严重罪行是由男性犯下的。当我们谈论基于性别的暴力时，大多数受害者是妇女和女童。但我们也知道，这部分源于我们需要改变社会看待男性方式的叙事。我们需要做得更好。
We need to do more. We need to think about people going into prison. They're coming from our families. They're coming from our communities. So it's not us versus them. And the people that work in prison, which are doing amazing, amazing jobs in the most incredibly hard circumstances with really high pressures, you know, the nurses have got such an incredibly hard job, the offices have got such an incredible out job.
我们需要做得更多。我们需要考虑进入监狱的人。他们来自我们的家庭。他们来自我们的社区。所以这不是我们与他们的对立。而在监狱工作的人，他们在极其困难的环境下，在巨大的压力下做着非常非常了不起的工作，你知道，护士们的工作极其艰苦，狱警们的工作也极其艰苦。
But these are the same people coming from the communities where the prisons are coming from. You know, so we need to be thinking about working, supporting people in prison means doing better for our communities. So this, us versus them, it really needs to change. For me, from today, for anyone listening to this discussion is really to keep that in mind, is that we're all in it together. I know it sounds a little bit corny, but that's the truth. And if we do start thinking about how to support each other at a very human level and think about, um, and think about, the struggles that we're going through and create space for those conversations, we might just, we might just be the catalyst to stop somebody from jumping in front of a train.
但这些人与监狱里的人来自同一个社区。你知道，所以我们需要考虑工作，支持监狱里的人意味着为我们的社区做得更好。所以这种我们与他们的对立，真的需要改变。对我来说，从今天开始，对于任何听这次讨论的人，真的要记住这一点，那就是我们都在同一条船上。我知道这听起来有点老套，但这是事实。如果我们开始思考如何在非常人性化的层面上互相支持，并思考，嗯，并思考，我们正在经历的挣扎，并为这些对话创造空间，我们可能只是，我们可能只是成为阻止某人跳向火车轨道的催化剂。
You know, and that is something that we can all do for each other. So that would be, I guess that's my parting thoughts for today. Thank you. Absolutely. Such important and powerful words. And thank you for saying them, Tanya. How about you, Natalie? Is there anything you'd like to leave us with or have us really consider? Thank you. I think I would just like to add on to Tanya's words. And for me, it's very much about when I talk about people in prison or two people in prison or anything, it's about there's more than just that snapshot. And I mentioned that earlier. And I think when I speak to people that don't work in prison, who aren't exposed to the information that we have and
你知道，这是我们所有人都能为彼此做的事情。所以我想这就是我今天临别的话。谢谢。绝对是。如此重要而有力的话语。谢谢你说出来，坦尼娅。你呢，娜塔莉？有什么你想留给我们，或者让我们真正考虑的事情吗？谢谢。我想我只想补充坦尼娅的话。对我来说，当我谈论监狱里的人或监狱里的两个人或任何事情时，这更多的是关于不仅仅是那个快照。我之前提到过这一点。我认为当我与那些不在监狱工作、没有接触到我们所拥有的信息的人交谈时，
understand how processes work and, you know, what may be got people there, It is really interesting to me that their views are basically, well, they're prisoners, they're bad people. And ultimately, that is the end of it. And as Tammy said, we're not trying to say that we're not trying to condone anything they've done. But ultimately, you can hold someone accountable and still have compassion. We're not saying that they're not two separate things. You can have them both. I think if we, you know, we talk about trauma-informed practice and the systemic Tan is very passionate about
了解流程是如何运作的，你知道，是什么导致人们到了那里，对我来说非常有趣的是，他们的观点基本上是，好吧，他们是囚犯，他们是坏人。最终，这就是结论。正如坦尼娅所说，我们并不是要试图说，我们并不是要宽恕他们所做的任何事情。但最终，你可以追究某人的责任，同时保持同情心。我们并不是说它们不是两件独立的事情。你可以两者兼得。我认为如果我们，你知道，我们谈论创伤知情实践和系统性，坦尼娅对此非常热衷，
and is working with, in our organisation, to support teams to be more trauma and for and to ask the right questions in the right way and to use the right language. But we are one kind of fraction of the people, the resources that will be in touch with those patients. So, you know, we need prison staff, offices, education, social workers, probation, to also use trauma and formal practices to, you know, to better understand and be able to de-escalate situations and to really understand what you're looking at when you're talking to someone and what they're saying, what they're not saying, they have that clinical curiosity and
并且正在我们的组织中工作，以支持团队更加创伤知情，并以正确的方式提出正确的问题，并使用正确的语言。但我们只是接触这些患者的人员和资源的一小部分。所以，你知道，我们需要监狱工作人员、狱警、教育工作者、社会工作者、缓刑官也使用创伤知情实践，以，你知道，更好地理解并能够缓和局势，并真正理解当你与某人交谈时你在看什么，以及他们在说什么，他们没说什么，他们拥有那种临床好奇心和
read more than just the words that somebody says, because it isn't always just what they say, is it so much more than that. But we're so caught up in the process of, you know, put someone in prison, they do this sentence, they go back out and then just go around in this cycle. It is just a struggle. And I think that's stigma in the community that that they're that inequality that exists. So, you know, women will leave prison and they will face more stigma leaving prison as a man would leave in prison. There is so much more jobs. People don't want to give people a job if you've been into prison. I'm not sure what the figures are on employment rate from prison leaveers, but it's not great because if you've been in prison, no one, it doesn't
读懂某人所说的话之外的含义，因为这并不总是仅仅是他们所说的，不是吗？远不止于此。但我们太沉迷于这个过程了，你知道，把某人关进监狱，他们服完刑，他们再出来，然后就在这个循环中打转。这真是一种挣扎。我认为社区中存在那种污名，那种不平等。所以，你知道，女性出狱后会面临比男性出狱后更多的污名。工作机会要少得多。如果你进过监狱，人们不想给你工作。我不确定监狱释放人员的就业率数据是多少，但并不乐观，因为如果你进过监狱，没有人，无论你是因为什么进去的，
matter what you've been in there for. They just see that you've been in HMP and judgments are made. So I think the message for me is society needs to remember that prisons are still part of our society. It is the same people on the outside. It's a reflection of what we have in the community, just a condensed version of people that need help. You know, these are not just prisoners. These are people who all need help, lots of different help from lots of different services. And then eventually they are going to come back outside into our communities with us on our buses, on our streets, in the house next door. you outside your school with your kids. They're going to be there. So let's help rehabilitate them
他们只看到你进过女王陛下监狱（HMP），然后就做出了判断。所以我认为我的信息是，社会需要记住监狱仍然是我们社会的一部分。外面的人也是一样。这是我们社区所拥有的反映，只是需要帮助的人的浓缩版本。你知道，这些人不仅仅是囚犯。他们是都需要帮助的人，需要来自许多不同服务的许多不同帮助。然后最终他们会回到外面的社区，和我们在一起，在我们的公交车上，在我们的街道上，在隔壁的房子里。你学校外面，和你的孩子在一起。他们会出现在那里。所以让我们帮助改造他们，
and give them the tools and resources they need to get their life back on track because somewhere it went wrong. It absolutely did. And what wonderful words to leave us with. And that's really touched me. I sort of feel myself tearing up really. But yeah, like this is this is a narrative we must all adopt. And yeah, thank you so much for your time today, both of you. I absolutely loved this episode. So interesting and it's a companion episode to the previous episode I did with Chris Dore K.C. So if you haven't already checked that out, I would urge you to do so. Please do let me know what this episode and what previous episodes have evoked for you. Did it connect with you? Has it inspired you to think differently about things? I would love it
并给他们所需的工具和资源，让他们重回正轨，因为在某个地方出了问题。确实如此。多么美妙的话语作为结束。这真的触动了我。我感觉自己真的要流泪了。但是是的，就像这是我们所有人都必须采用的叙事。是的，非常感谢你们今天的时间，你们两位。我非常喜欢这一集。非常有趣，这是我之前与克里斯·多尔御用大律师（Chris Dore K.C.）那一集的配套集。所以如果你还没有看过，我强烈建议你去看看。请务必让我知道这一集以及之前的剧集唤起了你什么。它与你产生共鸣了吗？它是否启发你以不同的方式思考事物？我很乐意
if you would let me know. Please do drop some supportive comments or let me. know what your thoughts are in the comments, which you can do on YouTube and which you can do on Spotify too with asking a question or making a comment. I hope you found it so useful. And if you have, the kindest thing you can do for any creator that you rate is to follow the show or subscribe to their channel. And it's totally for free as well. If you are an aspiring psychologist and you enjoy conversations like this, I think you'll really love the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join for just £30 a month with no minimum term. And if you want someone to one time with me, you can get that too when you join for either
如果你能让我知道。请在评论区留下一些支持性的评论，或者让我知道你的想法，你可以在YouTube上这样做，也可以在Spotify上通过提问或发表评论来做到。我希望你觉得它很有用。如果你觉得有用，你能为你评价的任何创作者做的最友善的事情就是关注该节目或订阅他们的频道。而且这也是完全免费的。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，并且喜欢这样的对话，我想你会非常喜欢“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership），你每月只需30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限。如果你想和我进行一对一的时间，当你加入
six or 12 months in one go. with Dr. Marianne Trin. Hello, my name is Veronica Kassova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a master's in psychology of mental health. Marianne recommended me the Clinical Psychologist Collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal
六个月或十二个月时，你也可以获得。与玛丽安·特林博士（Dr. Marianne Trin）。你好，我叫维罗妮卡·卡索娃（Veronica Kassova）。我住在爱丁堡，刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。当我在领英（LinkedIn）上建立人脉时，玛丽安向我推荐了“临床心理学家集体”（Clinical Psychologist Collective），我必须说我喜欢它。它是独一无二的。它就像一扇窗户，让我们看到了那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。这些故事独特、诚实，充满了只有个人
storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others, but with myself too. So, not fixating on becoming a psychologist, but enjoying life, grow, and the final results will come as a by-product. Marian, thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem, and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf.
叙事才能揭示的那种无形的智慧。我在我最珍视的故事中发现的一个共同点是，不仅要对他人的富有同情心，也要对自己富有同情心。所以，不要执着于成为一名心理学家，而是享受生活，成长，最终的结果会作为副产品出现。玛丽安，谢谢你花时间整理所有的故事。这本书是一块真正的瑰宝，我认为每一位有抱负的心理学家都应该在书架上放一本。
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。